foreign
[Music]
good morning
thank you everyone for joining us and
welcome to day two of Google Cloud next
I'm nikhila gaikwad I lead product
management for data sharing in bigquery
joining me today is Rupa Gupta who's the
chief technology officer of a very
esteemed partner haboo
in this session we'll talk about how you
can use data clean rooms to share data
securely
and in a privacy-centric way
before I dive into clean rooms I want to
take an opportunity to recognize some of
the trends and also opportunities that
we're seeing within the whole data
ecosystem and data sharing space
there is no doubt that data is the
driving force for Innovation and growth
for organizations
for many years you've seen customers
leverage their internal data and
operational data to generate insights
but what we're seeing more recently is
that more and more organizations are
sharing data and combining data with
external resources to generate new
insights
you know for example retailers are
working with media platforms to learn
about their customer preferences
we also see that manufacturers are
working with suppliers to optimize their
supply chain
so there's a lot of use cases where
leveraging external data leads to higher
levels of innovation there are many
studies that show that as well
and we actually
Google Cloud customers that use bigquery
share data we saw that there are
thousands of organizations sharing over
350 petabytes of data across
organizational boundaries per week
that is incredible and we've seen this
number grow by almost 40 percent in just
since last November
one of the reasons that December is
growing is because of a new service that
we announced and launched last year in
GA which is analytics sub uh for those
that don't know analytics sub is a
service a featured in part of bigquery
which is our data exchange and data
sharing platform that allows data
providers to publish their data and make
it available and data subscribers to
discover and find third-party data
sources and use that for their analysis
in fact in just one year we've seen
hundreds of organizations use analytics
sub and a lot of these data providers
have brought their data sets into
bigquery and made it available for
customers so we thank you for all the
partners that brought your data to
bigquery and made it available for many
data analysts to find Reliable data
sources and valuable data and use it
within their analysis
despite the growth and data sharing one
of the things that is on top of mind for
many organizations is privacy and
compliance
now more than ever your customers
understand are unaware of how their data
is being used and they expect to have
transparency on how that data is being
used for any analysis or anything that's
been shared
and at the same time we've seen
governments across the world Implement
and enforce privacy restrictions and
regulations
you see gdpr and CCPA are examples of
where there's more scrutiny towards how
data can be shared and of course if you
do share it without abiding by those
rules there are a lot of Hefty fines you
need to face
and particularly for those that are
working in the ad Tech and media
business
we see that the traditional ways of
individual and device identifiers are
also going away
so these companies are looking for new
ways to get the same level of insights
that they used to previously with the
new technology or platform
that's where data clean rooms come into
picture
so earlier this year we announced data
clean rooms and the goal with data
cleaners was to address some of the
challenges that we've seen with privacy
and compliance when it comes to sharing
data
with data clean rooms and bigquery data
clean rooms our goal is to enable
customers to create a secure
collaboration environment where they can
share combine and analyze data without
compromising on privacy
what does this really mean for you so if
you are a media publisher you can build
a clean room with your advertisers to
improve your advertising
if you are a financial institution and
you want to improve your fraud detection
you can build a cleaner with some of the
other institutions and share data and
privacy and secure way
and also if you're in healthcare
hospitals and pharmaceuticals can come
together and share data in a clean room
to identify how treatments are being
used with various patients
and the great thing about bigquery clean
rooms is that you can do all this
without having to move or copy your data
so I mentioned before we announced
bigquery clean rooms earlier this year
and I have a very special announcement
we're actually launching bigquery data
clean rooms into public preview today
[Applause]
so now you can go into your bigquery
console and go create your clean room
and let me actually dive into some of
the capabilities that we're launching
so the first thing that we're doing is
that we want to make it easy for you to
create and deploy clean rooms for your
use cases
so starting off we have a seamless UI
and workflow in bigquery where you can
orchestrate a cleaner
you can create a cleaner environment to
secure invite your partners to
collaborate with you within the clean
room and also set permissions on who can
contribute data and who can subscribe to
it
we also have we realize that when you're
working with clean rooms it's usually a
multi-party collaboration so we don't
have any restrictions on how many
parties you can invite to a clean room
and how many
tables or data sets you can join so we
call that anime collaboration
we also see that you know not all of
your partners that you invite to a clean
room might be part of Google cloud and
you might have partners that are sitting
on some of our friends on the other side
for different Cloud providers so we have
Integrations with bigquery Omni that
allow you to Federate and connect to
data that is not in Google Cloud as well
and lastly any data that's shared within
the clean room cannot be copied or
egressed so we have data egress
restrictions in place so if you make
your data available in a clean room none
of the subscribers that are running
queries against it can copy or remove
the underlying data
and everything that you see here can be
done programmatically through apis so if
you're a partner which you'll hear from
very soon you can build on top of
bigquery data clean rooms or if you want
to do this at scale for multiple use
cases you can use the apis
okay so now you know how to create and
deploy clean rooms the next step is for
a data contributor you need to make sure
that any data that's shared in the clean
room has the right type of Protections
in place to make sure there's no
sensitive information being shared
which is why we have analysis rules
analysis rules essentially
make it easier for you to determine as a
data contributor how data can be
analyzed and what are the restrictions
that you're putting in place for someone
that's running a query against this data
in a clean room
so we're starting off with a core
analysis rule which is aggregation so
any data that you shared in a clean room
you can create an aggregation privacy
policy that essentially provides you the
ability to select a privacy unit column
and the threshold so there's a minimum
number of distinct entities when you're
running a query against this data and
making it available
we also realize there's a lot of other
use cases as well for clean rooms so on
a roadmap we have overlap analysis so
this is really useful again if you're
doing uh retargeting for audiences or
you know more of the core use cases
where you're trying to compare the
overlap between two different data sets
so you'll have overlap restrictions
you'll also have the ability to use more
Advanced Techniques like differential
privacy which is the key for anonymizing
your data
you also have restrictions where you can
prevent someone from joining to a
certain column that's being shared in a
cleaner for a table
so all these great functionalities are
built into created clean rooms so you
can use SQL and also some of the
workflows directly in the UI to
configure it
all right so now you can create a
cleaner and deploy it as a data
contributor you can make sure that you
have the right Protections in place when
you make your data available
so the next step is for you to monitor
this so you heard from Married customers
that it's important for someone that's
making data available within a clean
room that they can track who's using the
data and also monitor the usage
so bigquery data clean rooms is built on
top of analytics sub so you get
subscriptions and some of the built-in
functionality where you can see who's
subscribing to your clean room and you
can revoke access at any time and you
can also use usage metrics which gives
you information about what types of
queries are being run against this data
so you'll find information on which you
know it's table which column is being
created frequently and how customers are
actually using that information
all right so now you can create your
clean rooms you can set analysis rules
and you can track and monitor this
often a lot of customers come to us and
say great this is useful for my use case
but what about Google data
well if you don't know we actually have
a clean room that we launched back in
2017 for Google ads and Google campaign
events and this is called ads data hub
in fact Google was the first company to
bring to Market I did a clean room
solution but as data for marketers
we recognize that many of you might be
leveraging that to get insights and what
you would like to do is also use ads
data in conjunction with the clean rooms
that you're creating and using in
bigquery
so which is why we are going to
integrate and connect with ads data Hub
directly in bigquery so we have coming
up as part of our GA is that you will be
able to connect to ads data hub
have your first party data within
bigquery and run queries directly in the
bigquery console against Google campaign
data
all right so we talked about how you can
use bigquery data clean rooms to create
and deploy set analysis rules and you
got a little bit of glimpse of how you
can track usage and also what's coming
up in our roadmap
and I've used the word bigquery a few
times and those of you that are not
familiar with bigquery I want to give
you a little bit of insight into why we
chose to build data clean rooms on top
of the bigquery platform
so one of the unique things of how
bigquery is built is its architecture it
separates out storage and compute and
this is really important as someone that
is creating a cleaner and deploying this
because as someone who's contributing
data the only cost that you would incur
when you make data available in the
clean room is storage
and for someone that is running analysis
or running queries against data in a
clean room the only cost you to incur
are the queries and bigquery gives you
the ability to separate those two things
out so again you can scale and the whole
point is that you're not moving the data
from words in place
also bigquery has a lot of native
Integrations we start with you know I
haven't used the word AI since about 12
minutes into the presentation but we
know it's important for not only for you
to be able to create analysis and
queries but also build models on top of
data that you're sharing so bigquery has
built-in bigquery ml where you can build
and operationalize models directly in
SQL so it's easy for you to analyze your
data and build models on top of it and
share it out to your analysts
at the same time we realize that a lot
of the end users that are consuming
insights about data that's made
available in the clean room are often
looking at reporting they're not coming
into bigquery and running SQL
which is why bigquery makes it easy for
you to integrate with many of the other
bi platforms such as looker for you to
be able to visualize some of the
insights that you're getting out of a
cleaner
so once you create and deploy your clean
rooms set your analysis rules run
queries you can build reporting that's
very rich for your end users and
business users so they can visualize
that information again they don't have
to use queries or run an analysis in
bigquery they can see everything
directly in the bi reporting tool
so not only are you getting access to
all these rich capabilities in bigquery
you essentially have access to the
entire Google's data and AI Suite
so we bigquery you probably saw in some
of the earlier sessions has Integrations
with vertex AI and we're doing a lot of
work to make sure that
developers and data Engineers that are
working across these different products
have seamless Integrations and again
with bigquery data clean rooms you'll be
able to leverage these capabilities
directly in bigquery again without
having to to move your data out or
needing any other new infrastructure or
another platform so everything is built
in and it's native
all right so you learned a little bit
about how bigquery data clean rooms work
and some of its capabilities let me give
you a good example of how customers are
leveraging bigquery clean rooms and what
a typical architecture might look like
for you
so imagine that you are a retailer
that's collaborating with a cpg and this
is very common you can also think about
a media publisher collaborating with an
Advertiser
so retailer has information on some of
the sales transactions POS data they
have information on you know who visited
the store
Etc
whereas the cpg has information on the
campaigns that they've run for their
brand or product for these customers
typically a cpg would like to know you
know what is the ROI that they're
getting for the campaigns that they're
running
for with this particular retailer and
how many conversions have they had
so what they would do is they would
agree to collaborate in a clean room
environment so they're sharing data in a
secure collaboration environment within
the cleaner
and the process for them to do that
within bigquery is as follows
so the first thing you would do is go
into analytics sub similar to how you
would create secure data exchanges you
go create a cleaner so in this case
imagine the retail is creating a retail
media cleaner
The Next Step because it's the retailer
that's making and creating this cleaner
is for the retailer to make their data
available so in their bigquery project
they would essentially combine all the
source data or the tables that they want
to make available into view
and essentially prepare the view to make
available inside the cleaner
once you have your view configured the
next step is for you to apply your
analysis rules so think about
aggregation differential privacy or lab
which I talked about
you would enforce those analysis rules
on this View and then you would make
this view available in the clean room as
a listing
again throughout this whole process
you're not copying or moving the data
you're just making the data available in
the clean room for someone to come in
and subscribe and run analysis against
so the data stays in place
so once you've publish this into a clean
room
now this is ready for the cpg or who is
running the analysis for them to
subscribe to this cleaner and run their
analysis so what a cpg would do is come
in in their own brick query project
And subscribe to the cleaner
what this will do is create what we call
a linked data set in their project this
link data set again is not a copy it's
essentially a pointer back to the shared
data in this case you have all the
restrictions that the data contributor
or the retailer has set for the
transactions data they're making
available
once you do this and of course the cpg
would have their own data that they have
for the campaigns and customers they're
targeting
so what they would do is essentially
combine that data with the subscribed
data from the retailer
run a query against this data and what
they would see in the results set is the
combination of data that that have been
combined both from the retailer and the
cpg
so in this whole process no one has
moved their data from their project it
stays in place
what the retailer has done is that
they've made their data available with
privacy protections these protections
are enforced at the time that there are
queries that are being run
and again the result set is made
available to who is running the query in
this case the cpg
with their privacy protections and Bliss
so that's pretty much the end-to-end of
a typical use case of how you would use
bigquery clean rooms in a retailer and
cpg conducts you can also Imagine in
this case a cpg can also share data back
into this clean room and the retailer
can subscribe to that data and run their
analysis so you can certainly expand
this to a multi-party collaboration and
if you'd like you can also have an
entity resolution provider bring their
match tables into a clean room so you
can join the spare data sets so there's
a lot of interesting use cases and
architectures that you can do but the
goal is that you're not moving the data
out you have the right Protections in
place to protect the sensitive
information and you can do all this
directly in bigquery
well we actually had a preview for big
created clean rooms for some of our
select customers and L'Oreal actually
used bigquery clean rooms for many of
their marketing use cases and they found
a lot of success with using bigquery
clean rooms for their use cases so they
can improve their retargeting for
marketers and also work directly with
the brands that they're collaborating
with and provide this end-to-end
functionality
one of the most important things for a
lot of Brands is having that sort of
closer measurement and being able to
understand the ROI for the dollars that
they're spending for the campaigns that
they're running so this is really
helping L'Oreal succeed with providing
those insights back to the brands that
they're working with
and we realized that with clean rooms we
can't be successful alone so what we're
doing is that we're collaborating with
many of our partners
so for identity resolution or entity
resolution we're working with live ramp
and Transunion so they can provide you
the ability to join disparate data sets
directly in bigquery
we're also working with tumult labs to
be able to do more advanced differential
privacy or anonymization against your
data
and lastly we're working with data
cleaner orchestrators to be able to
orchestrate clean rooms on behalf of
others and be a neutral third party in
the context of creating cleaner and for
that we have haboo and Rupa Gupta is
going to give you a little bit of
insights on how haboo has built their
functionality and their experiences on
top of bigquery data cleaners so good
afternoon
[Applause]
thank you Nicole uh uh you know before
we start and talk about Habu
I would love to hear from you guys
before coming into this room did you
guys how many of you have dabbled with
clean rooms know a little bit about
clean rooms have done something with
clean rooms
awesome that's a that's a great set so
by the end of this session
it won't be just a data scientists the
data Engineers even The Savvy business
users among you you will be amazed by
the power of clean rooms imagine being
able to join hands with your partners
with no movement of data all done in a
privacy safe manner
so let me introduce you to Habu Habu is
a data cleanup software company it has
been uh you know we are headquartered in
San Francisco we do this across a whole
bunch of different you know Cloud
providers and all and today we are going
to talk about bigquery so
is scalable
it's simple and it's smart
so how do we do this exactly so there
are three key pillars to it
if you look at the bottom it's
connect what is connect
we connect directly to your data you
know gone are the days when you have to
send files over gone are the days when
you have to figure out what format is it
parquet is it CSV is it gzip all those
days are gone we connect directly to
your data
and then comes comply look with data
rules are really important
with Habu workflows happen with the
right governance the right permissions
and the right approvals
and finally collaborate this is where
Advanced collaboration is a breeze
because we have automated workflows we
have pre-built analysis we have query
templates which is ready to roll out
insights and business outcomes
so we all know the power of bigquery
nikhil already talked about a whole
bunch of things uh that bigquery can do
if you think about bigquery with Habu it
takes collaborative intelligence to the
next level
I would say it's like bigquery on
steroids
now why do businesses actually use the
combination the really powerful
combination of Habu and bigquery first
it's a time to value if you're looking
for for automated work flows pre-built
analysis
where clean room can be provisioned
across many many partners
Habu delivers all of it
I would say it's like a Swiss knife of
data collaboration
now
on top of that Habu gets along
flawlessly with different Tech stacks
it's uh the example that I give is it's
like a cool kid uh who goes to a party
and actually can mingle with any crowd
at the party
it because remember one thing you have
chosen your stack your partners have
chosen their stack
but just because you have you may have
chosen different technology does not
mean that as a business you should not
be able to collaborate
and then finally Habu throws the party
for data and product teams but it also
rolls out the red carpet for the
business teams if you're trying to
implement use cases if you're trying to
derive insights if you're thinking about
actionable decisions Habu is there for
you
it is a party that none of you want to
miss
now let me paint a picture with the
example that I think nikhil started with
around retailer and cpg and let's put a
pin on the party because we'll get back
to it
so what we have seen with our with our
with our clients and partners there are
three key things that they do with clean
rooms one is around planning
optimization and measurement
only by querying the full user level
data with the right privacy and
governance controls on top of that only
then companies can effectively plan
optimize and measure
next moving beyond insights companies
are also trying to take it to the next
level and activation they want to do
activation in addressable media channels
and then finally more than SQL think
about propriety code think about when
you're collaborating how can you engage
enrich your data enrich the partners
data enrich the combined data using
propriety code
now here's an inside Peak into habu's
operation
remember we talked about a party that
you all want to join and hopefully
you'll join uh this is this is where uh
look if you're a for data Engineers you
know data scientists wherever there's
data there's a party but I want everyone
including the business users the data
analysts everyone to come to this party
so let's see how this goes
so this is where in Habu the Magic
Begins so right now we're in a
pre-planning phase we are planning a
data party so
there are data connections here you
connect to your data whether it's your
bigquery table whether it's authorized
views whether it's GCS locations what
have you this is where you connect to
the data
now once you have connected the data
this is now you're you're setting a
stage for the clean Loop this is your
setting I'm going to create a bigquery
you know and now you are setting some
restrictions on it so this is where you
said I'm going to put differential
privacy controls over it which includes
noise and Cayman enforcements this
ensures that no individual level data is
exposed ever out of the screen room
now next what you do is you have row and
column level filtering this is where you
as a data owner tell us what are the
rows and the columns that you want to
bring into the clean room this gives you
total control over the data that goes
into the analysis
now the stage is set it's time for some
invitations to be sent you can extend an
invitation to know your collaborator
with a very simple email workflow
remember this can be a multi-particle in
room and you can have many partners and
and now invites are out collaborators
are coming in they are managing their
own data sets remember they are putting
the same restrictions that you put in
through row and collaborative filtering
through analysis rules all is happening
now each analysis and pre-built
templates now becomes a collaborative
effort this is with everyone bringing
their data sets to the table
with the restrictions that they had put
in imagine this in a party scenario it's
like a music where you are you know
you're collaborating with someone I love
Bollywood for example music I know
nikhil loves hip-hop so it's it's a
collaboration of all the different music
types and we know in this collaboration
party both Bollywood and Hip-Hop will be
a hit so this is where you are making
that uh connection
now
the stage is set
the lights are bright music is on and
now it's time for the information to
flow this is where you can execute these
questions you can schedule them the
results start pouring in and you can
also access all of this via apis
but there are two personas that we
talked about one was the data and
proactive we haven't forgotten about
them
data and product team can create their
own templates they can distribute them
all across so we have a question Builder
where you can write your own SQL or you
can write your own code we also have a
cool assistant we have to talk about gen
AI uh this is a cool assistant a Genera
assistant that actually is like a
co-pilot for you for the data and
product teams it helps you write the SQL
improve your SQL and on top of that it
also helps you explain the SQL to your
collaborators
you can explain it at different levels
you can explain to a business user you
can also explain to a more technical
user all that is available in the hubu
platform
and then finally we have not forgotten
about our business users Habu comes
equipped with a bi tool we have
dashboards there are kpi settings there
are alert configurations and we also
have a
chat module which allows you to question
ask questions to your data come to
conclusions ask next questions come up
with kpis come up with alerts all that
it can be done with Hubble it's like
giving the Keys of the Kingdom to your
business users with the right
restrictions in place
awesome so as this session wraps up you
know I would leave you all with the
thought that we started with regardless
of what role you play there is a data
scientist data engineer with your
business user clean room offers you a
chance to enrich your data with Partners
data in a privacy safe manner no
movement of data required seamless
efficient collaboration
thank you with that I'll pass it on to
nikhil
thank you
thank you Rebecca that was wonderful and
it just goes to show that how data
orchestrators like haboo and partners
that have built amazing experiences on
top of bigquery and it's very seamless
especially if you're again trying to go
to market very quickly and make your
clean room offering available within
your bigquery
so one thing I want to wrap up is uh
essentially help you answer the question
of why choose Google Cloud for data
cleaners
well first of all as I mentioned before
we were the first to market for data
clean rooms with ads data Hub and we've
built a lot of the technology for ads
data Hub on top of bigquery and what
we're doing now is making that
technology available for you to use your
own use case
second thing is that we have the Best in
Class tools to protect your sensitive
data and also govern the data directly
in bigquery
and all of this available is available
in the Google data and AI platform
you also get access to the complete
ecosystem as we talked about before we
have analytics sub that has hundreds of
data providers that have thousands of
data sets that you have access to so you
can enrich your data and combine it and
join it to get new insights and
Innovation for your organization
and last but not least we are the price
performance leader so I talked about the
unique capabilities of bigquery to
separate out storage and compute again
this is really useful as you're trying
to scale out and make clean rooms
available for your partners and it
really gives you the ability to be
flexible with how your data is being
used in the context of not only your
internal analysis but also in the
context of cleaners
so as you come to a wrap I encourage you
now that we are in public preview to go
try out bigquery data clean rooms
directly in your console
rook and I will be here to answer any
questions that you have but thank you
all for joining
foreign